- I've been very blessed to have had
some absolutely amazing
friendships in my life.
And while many of them have come and gone,
some of them got married,
some of them moved town,
one of them became a priest, actually.
(crowd laughing)
But anyways.
All the amazing friends in my
life have taught me something
about what it means to be me.
Because I think you view
yourself through the eyes
of other people, especially
people you're close with.
So I think it's really
important to surround yourself
with the right people, to form
your tribe with intention.
You wanna surround yourself with people
who make you a better person.
And for the most part those
types of relationships
are gonna be friendships,
but you don't get quality
friendships by following
a step-by-step action plan
or something like that.
Some of the best
relationships I've ever had
in my life seem to have
just randomly happened
when I wasn't really
expecting it whatsoever.
So needless to say with this video
I'm not interested in giving
you a step-by-step guide
as to how to make everyone
want to be your friend,
or anything like that,
because I think that's
kind of futile and dumb.
But I do wanna talk about
some really useful things
that I've learned throughout my life,
that have really helped
me make friends easier
and make higher quality friends.
And overall just connect with
people a lot more genuinely.
♪ Somebody sexy, tell 'em hey ♪
♪ Give me ev-- ♪
- The number one tip that I have is to
always assume initiative.
So back when I was like 15 or 16 years old
I was browsing Reddit
self-improvement forums
and stuff like that.
I was on like r/socialskills
and I came across this post
that pretty much changed my entire life.
I've been looking everywhere
for this one post,
but I can't find it anywhere.
So if someone can help me out
with this, that'd be great.
But in the post, there was
this guy who talked about
how he didn't have very many friends,
and the friends that he did
have were starting to fade away
and he didn't know why.
He was kind of a loner,
kind of an introvert,
and all these friends started
to just drift away from him,
and he was getting really upset.
Until the very last friend that he had
finally stopped calling him.
Angry, confused, and saddened by this,
this Reddit poster runs up to his friend
and says, "Dude, where'd you go?
"Why'd you stop calling me?
"Why don't you invite
me to stuff anymore?"
And his friend turned
to him and simply said,
"It's 'cause you don't invite me anywhere.
"I figured you didn't
like hanging out with me."
And this really kind of
changed my perspective
because I just never
invited people anywhere.
I always waited for the invitation.
I was always sitting there on my butt,
wondering why nobody was inviting me
to cool parties and stuff.
And I eventually realized
that I wasn't making any effort whatsoever
to make plans and call people
up, invite them to stuff.
If you don't have very many friends
and you tend to not do things very often
and you wanna be someone
who does things with people,
then take control.
Just like any other aspect of your life,
if you wanna change
something it's up to you
because it's your life.
So take control of your
social life as well.
Always assume initiative.
If you wanna do something fun,
come up with an idea, invite
the person to that idea.
If they don't wanna come
to that idea, leave 'em be.
Is that recording?
- [Man] I recorded you peeing.
- Did you?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Okay, so the next big
thing that I've learned
is that honesty is the antidote.
One of the biggest pitfalls
in any social interaction
is the fear of voicing your
opinion, or being controversial,
or politically incorrect, or offensive.
But this fear really has to go
if anybody is to know who
you are in this world.
Because so many people are so agreeable,
they're extremely careful about
every little thing they say,
they're making sure they're
not hurting anyone's feelings.
They're making sure that they're laughing
at everyone's jokes.
They're being very pleasant.
And what this eventually does
is that you tend to be seen
by a large amount of people
as, oh yeah, he's nice.
People are kinda, they
don't really know you
but you're unoffensive to them
so you're okay to have around.
You'll be liked by everyone,
but loved by no one.
So if you're the kind of person
who doesn't ever want to
make any sort of waves,
or make anyone feel uncomfortable,
and you find it really
hard to make it past
kind of a surface level acquaintanceship
with most people, then
that's probably the reason.
By not voicing your true opinions,
by not speaking honestly about things
that you're passionate about,
or things that you've learned,
or standing up for what's right,
you're basically concealing
your identity from people.
And people don't tend to bond with people
that they don't know at all.
Especially people who they don't trust.
I feel like everybody has
a few people in their life
that when they come across
them in a grocery store,
or something like that,
you have the exact same
conversation every single time.
"Hey man, how's it goin'?
"Oh yeah that's cool, how's
the hockey team goin'?
"Oh yeah, sweet yeah.
"So you gettin' on the ice a lot?
"Oh, that's good man, that's good man.
"Yeah, your wife's family's all good?
"Oh, that's good, that's good.
"Well, I'm gonna let you
go I gotta get running,
"but great running into you,
"I'll see you some other time."
I feel like I have that conversation
with like eight to 10 people in my life.
Usually just people I play hockey with
or something like that.
So I'm not saying you need
to get past that stage
with every single person
that you meet in this world,
and form deep friendships with
everybody you lock eyes with.
But what I am saying is
that if you're interested
in forming deeper
relationships with people
then you have to be willing to kinda
break out of that small talk,
ask questions you're
actually curious about,
and that you might think is
like a weird thing to ask,
but if you wanna ask it, just
get good at just asking it.
When you say something
that's controversial
and polarizing, people
can do either two things.
They can either really bond
with what you're saying
and be like, "Yeah, man, that's awesome.
"I totally agree."
Or they can be like, "I'm outta here.
"This guy's cracked."
And both of those things
are a really good thing
because of my next point,
which is rejection is a very useful tool.
When you communicate honestly,
when you wear your
opinions on your sleeve,
when you're not afraid to be controversial
and be who you are in
front of other people,
then you're inevitably
gonna make a lot of people
run the other way because they
completely disagree with you.
And that's a very good thing
because you can find out very quickly
who the people who are
actually staying are.
And the people who are
staying are probably people
who you can actually bond with.
And I was thinking about
this the other day,
because I think rejection
is like an inevitable thing
that always happens if
people are incompatible.
And it can either happen right away,
or it happens very
gradually over the course
of a very painful and toxic relationship.
A quick rejection is one where
one person starts talking
and the other person starts talking,
you don't vibe with that person at all
so you kinda go the other way
and you never talk with that person again.
That's an acute rejection.
From a dating perspective,
you walk up to a girl, or a guy,
or whoever you're approaching
and you're all like,
"Hey baby."
And then they're like,
"Nah, get out of here.
"You suck, you smell, your
breath is bad, I don't like you."
And then that's it.
You're like, ah okay, that kinda sucks.
But fair enough, I should
probably brush my teeth.
That's an acute rejection,
and you never have to talk
with that person again.
But that's what happens when
people are being honest.
They're saying what they mean.
One person's like,
"Hey, I'm interested in bonding with you."
The other person's like, "No, go away."
And then they split up.
I think that's absolutely perfect.
It's honest, communication,
clear cut results.
But a gradual rejection is something
that people don't really
think about a lot.
And I think it's when two
people are incompatible
but neither of them are very
good at communicating honestly.
So these two types of
people might actually
get into a friendship or a relationship,
and then find out later down the road
that they actually don't
really like each other at all,
and they resent tons of things about them.
So they start to become
bitter at each other,
and start to get mad at their
fundamental differences.
Start to get petty about
little things like,
if they leave a banana on the table
and you lash out at them.
But you're not really
lashing out of the banana,
you're lashing out of the
fact that you disagree
about religious and political things.
But you never sorted it out to begin with
and now you have to deal with
all this like drama later.
It's just an absolute mess.
But usually that only happens
because two parties aren't
really communicating
very honestly at the beginning.
They can't see the
differences right off the bat,
evaluate them, and then realize,
you know what, this person's
so much different than me,
This is probably gonna cause
a lot of pain and turmoil
down the road so I'm just gonna split
before it gets too deep.
So if someone's incompatible with you,
rejection and no matter what.
It can either happen right
away, or way down the road.
So opt for honest communication
and quick rejection.
(chuckling)
This is probably the
most un-fun, unflattering
social interaction advice of all time.
Hey, it's Better Ideas here,
here's how to get rejected
nine times outta 10.
So this last bit of advice
is all about demographics.
And I picked up this
bit of information from
"Models" by Mark Manson,
which is actually a book about dating,
and relationships, and stuff like that.
But this honestly applies to friendships
or any kind of relationship
that you want to enter into.
So a lot of people complain
that they can't meet anyone like them.
They're a special little snowflake,
they have their own little
interests and hobbies.
Maybe they have some weird hobbies,
and interests, and
pretty strange opinions.
And they lament because
they can never find
their tribe, their people.
People who think exactly like them,
people they can just hit it
off with and have a great time.
They can spew all their bizarre opinions
about whatever, together.
But people get sad because
they can't find people who get them.
Well, a lot of people look
in the most general places,
the most general public venues of all time
for their soulmate, their best friend.
They're not actually evaluating
what interests they have,
what values they hold,
and going to the places
where those people exist.
You want to increase your chances
of finding people that you connect with.
That's just basic
demographics, it's statistics.
Come on.
If you're religious start
actually going to that church
young adults group that
you've been avoiding.
There are a lot of people who
think like you in that group.
If you're into sports,
you're really athletic,
then join an intramural
or communal sports team.
Start to get involved with
the extracurricular events
and the little optional group
meetups and stuff like that.
Go where your people are.
There are people who share your hobbies
and your passions, go there.
But sometimes you might not
have a crazy proficiency
in every single one of your hobbies.
So you're afraid that if you go
to one of those group meetups,
like a photography club,
everyone's gonna laugh
at you because you suck.
You're not good at all,
you should probably put
down the camera and never
take a picture again.
But luckily if you use
today's video sponsor,
Skillshare, that'll never happen to you.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes
covering dozens of topics.
Everything from photography,
to cinematography,
to cooking, to coding,
even How to Hone Your Voice
Online with Nathaniel Drew,
which is the class that
I've most recently taken.
And it's honestly such a great class
especially for people
who have been dabbling
with the idea of starting a
YouTube channel or a blog.
Maybe you see some of
your favorite YouTubers,
and you think to yourself,
maybe I can do that.
Well, a great place to start
to give you the right tools
and mindset to be able
to tackle that obstacle
is Nathaniel Drew's class.
His class, like so many other classes
on Skillshare are designed
to be extremely practical.
So whatever you learn on Skillshare
you can easily apply it to
your real life pursuits.
And it's so affordable,
especially when you compare it
to in-person classes and workshops.
If you pay for the annual membership,
it comes in at less than $10 a month.
And Skillshare is doing this awesome thing
where for a limited time only,
if you use my link in
the description below,
you click it, you get a free
trial to Skillshare premium.
Which means right now,
if you click the link
you can check out Nathaniel
Drew's class for free,
as well as all the other
classes on Skillshare.
So make sure you take
advantage of that link,
learn something new,
explore your creativity,
and as usual, have a great time.
If you liked this video,
make sure to hit like,
because when you hit like
the algorithm blesses me
and it shoves my bald head
into other people's homepages,
helping them out,
potentially helping them
make friends and stuff.
It helps me out too,
so it's kind of a win-win for everybody.
So if you just hit that like,
the world is a better place instantly.
If you're lurking here and
this is the billionth time
that you've seen my face and
you haven't hit subscribe yet,
make sure to hit subscribe
and hit the bell icon
so that you get notified
when I upload new content.
We also have a Facebook
page, an Instagram page,
a subreddit, and I just did
a subreddit reaction video
on my second channel.
I'll put the link in the description
so you can check that out.
If you haven't noticed already, actually,
the backdrop kinda
looks like my old place,
but I'm in my new place
now, getting some stability.
There's another video
coming out like less than
a week from now, two weeks from now,
there's also lots of activity
on the second channel
coming up, but there also
has been a little bit before.
So if you need more content
and Better Ideas isn't enough,
and you wanna see me more,
go to the second channel
where there's more content.
Catch you next.